in all of human history yeah that's like
women bring less to the table nowadays
in terms
we have women on the table my guy how
table would be pretty is common no no no
no I'm not saying I'm not saying I'm not
saying
I'm not saying nothing I'm not saying
that's in pretty because anyone could be
pretty you could go and get plastic
surgery and be a [ __ ] pretty [ __ ]
you know what I mean yeah but for me
that's true but as a woman comes down to
like women and men provide different
things so like as a woman you provide I
don't know obviously everyone's got
their own mindsets but men provide like
they are providers as we're woman they
like they cook they look after the
children
how many women really how many women
really cook and clean it's automated now
I think the difference is if you're
grateful City girl she's never gonna go
cook for you she's not looking for you
she's not gonna take care of the kids
she's not gonna do anything that you
look for in a woman but if you go for a
respectful woman a woman that's been
raised right in a family her family's
taught her good manners and everything
yoga gonna get everything that you want
but there's not as many of those that's
true that's true but that's because of
society nowadays I would say I would say
the average age of first marriage is 31
in the UK though you're right it's 27 28
it's like 35 in Ireland like it's in the
west it's an epidemic basically but
everyone in America how many bodies does
a girl have by 31 35 28 and I'm saying
like people used to marry men used to
know they could provide for a girl and
get a young virgin they can't get that
anymore do you know why I think women
need to kind of have a higher standard
than men because they see if I'm a girl
and I meet a guy in my standards the
subpar I sleep with him doesn't work out
happens again happens again when my body
can't get to a certain level I'm seen as
a hoe I'm seeing this you can't watch
that but a guy could have double triple
my body count and it doesn't devalue
himself
we have to have a higher standard
because if we don't and we act like when
I say well guys can do it that's not
getting me no by any point I'm still at
home but whatever wouldn't it make more
sense to ask those guys what it was but
guys
I'm saying like like yeah like ask the
men what they want and try to be more of
what they want because guys this this is
my point like he said like he said when
I go want to bend a guy will say he'll
go rent a bins this is what guys love
the chase guys love this guys that
aren't ready to settle down love to
chase guys they aren't actually looking
to settle down they love the chase guys
they're actually looking for something
serious you see the differences I talked
to men like that like I've talked to men
like successful attractive men like I'm
looking to match make them yeah and
they're not really into the game if
they're if they're looking for a wife
but the key is a lot of times like we
date guys our age they're not looking
for a wife
but also ladies
you like men with sexual experience no I
don't know
what I'm saying
so let me let me let me ask you a very
honest question yeah
would you date a virgin yeah yeah yeah
you would date a virgin so Amanda he
doesn't know your body he doesn't know
how to give you an orgasm there's no
hard to have sex
most guys already don't know how to give
an orgasm I need to say that for one but
the question is do you want to do you
want this hang on I don't want it
do you want your man to please you of
course okay so to please you he needs to
have experience do you know why I say no
happiness ladies calm the hell down like
seriously calm down you're too good with
the questions what I'm trying to say is
a man if you want a man to please you
he's going to have to have sexual
experience he's
saying oh yeah calm yourself
okay he's going to have to have sexual
experience okay so to have sex
experience and to learn how to please
you he's going to have to know his way
around a woman's body if he doesn't know
his way around a woman's body you're
gonna go for the man who's slanging Dick
X Y and Z and knows how to please you
not really me personally
I'm Gonna Let You Go first you even talk
too much so go ahead then then you then
you then you okay so go ahead so me
personally
um I think I still would go over virgin
you never know it might be a hit wonder
you never know you never know personally
so I'm not gonna enjoy them
can I ask you a question
so is it attractive to you if a guy he's
bringing you to his room and you have to
tell him what to do is that or is it
attractive when he just knows what to do
but sis imagine if he no no no answer
the questions
so is it attractive like you're on a
date with a guy it goes well whatever
however long it takes you he brings you
home back to his place and he's like oh
[ __ ] what do I do
and he's like how do I how does this
work is is that attractive to you you
know what I'm a very dominant woman okay
my dog would not put me on me off okay
so so you're gonna tell him other
positions you're going to tell them
everything
would you say the best sex you've ever
had was with a guy with little
experience almost it's a good experience
wow
how
um it's kind of positive that because
it's like how do I know what no at least
I've really gone into a deal you can
usually tell you can you wait wait can
you usually you can usually tell based
on how attractive he is of other girls
like him okay okay and that and that in
that sense yeah you're right yes I'm
more attracted to that okay
just fine that's normal that makes sense
okay okay you could go and then and then
you two will go
why did it take so long to just admit
something that's so big no because it's
like what if I'm okay no but the thing
is it's basic you want a guy that knows
what he's doing you don't want a guy who
doesn't know what he's doing you don't
want a guy who's that oh he said okay to
touch on me
no because that's a virgin you know it
is
wait wait wait wait wait wait you want a
guy that knows what he's doing so when
so when I'm when I'm asking it well when
we're asking these questions why why cap
why
because I don't want to be masculine
anymore so therefore oh sorry I want
someone that is experienced because I'm
tired of being masculine of course you
want someone to take control I feel like
naturally I'd I don't know about every
other woman I'm not gonna quote for them
but I've had to cook for my younger
siblings and all them different type of
things you know I'm trying to say and I
had to take my own so you feel like
you're scared for yes yes and you don't
like it no no okay okay well I feel like
the this generation initiates all of
that no and and I agree you're that's
normal most girls don't want to date
virgins but why do we have to jump
through hoops to get to this answer
you know what I've never been faced with
it so I'd be like if I was I think I'd
be a bit more open-minded about it but
you know what I'm saying it's like you
prefer wait wait you prefer men with
experience we all do of course we all do
that but I think that's with everyone
but you might not always get that so you
can't be shallow minded okay okay you
can you can go next and you go then you
go okay
with experience don't get me wrong if
you've got someone that's the extreme so
like you are saying magic you don't want
to touch you I thought that's an extreme
example that's not virgins because I've
slept with virgins I've been a virgin
and that's not been the case you mean
when you were younger
exactly let me explain let me land
though let me learn me personally
I thought no because I hate arrogant
guys and I hate guys that can't be like
I've been top things I know what I'm
doing no every single individual body is
different so what you did on her her and
her has nothing to do with what you do
with me see me personally I can't have
sex with you if I don't like you if I
don't have an emotional connection so
that's step one let me ask you something
I ask you a question really quick really
quick yeah the guy that you love is he
arrogant
um he is arrogant a little bit no let me
laugh because arrogant no his arrogant
has nothing to do with his sexual
performance he says arrogant you said
you don't let arrogant guys but your
guys no I don't like guys that are no I
don't like guys just focus on yourself
but you have to understand from the
guy's point of view this is confusing
because the guy no wait wait the guy
that you're breaking all of your rules
for I imagine you're not normally a side
chick imagine
I imagine you're not normally a side
chick yes or no of course okay so this
is the guy you're breaking your rules
so it's confusing to men when you say
you don't like arrogant guys but the guy
that you're breaking all of your rules
for and you've been with for a year and
a half and three weeks and you found out
he had a girlfriend is arrogant based on
your own words I said I don't like guys
who are arrogant when it comes to sexual
experience your contradiction no no yeah
let me land because you just keep
talking over me we've been letting you
love you yeah any point listen I've
openly said I've openly said that I'm a
hypocrite don't get me wrong however
when I said I don't like guys that are
out so we shouldn't listen to you though
no no no no I have some point though no
listen no listen I don't like guys that
are arrogant just entertainment just
so when a guy comes and said oh I've got
nine inches well I know I've talked bad
girls that's a completely your size and
your experience like your sexual
experience is completely original
sexual experience Jennifer Jennifer guys
it's completely Jennifer
yeah
all right all right 30 seconds
the guy okay that I've broke all my
rules for he does nothing special
nothing spectacular it's all about the
shape it's all about the fit to his
thing to my thing and it's all about
this it's all about the sexual
attraction it has nothing to do with
what he does because I can't sit here
and says he does anything out of the
ordinary that I've seen guys go more out
of the ordinary and it just doesn't bang
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible